el título del libro de thomas piketty es
el capital en el siglo 21 y vale la pena
hablar sobre el término de capital si
vamos a producir cualquier cosa
necesitamos alguna entrada factores para
dicha producción imaginemos que tenemos
una granja la salida de esta granja es
alimento que deberemos tener como
entrada bueno dibujamos nuestra granja
como un círculo aquí esta granja nuestra
producción o nuestra salida es alimentos
y nuestras entradas cuáles serán
pues vamos a necesitar tierra
vamos a necesitar agua
también vamos a necesitar equipo
y sin duda vamos a necesitar semillas
animales y demás cosas que llamaremos
insumos y por supuesto vamos a necesitar
personas que junten todas estas cosas y
se pongan a trabajar la tierra preparen
el terreno para plantar siempre las
semillas cosechan los cultivos y
administren todas las operaciones así
pues vamos a necesitar mano de obra si
tomamos todos estos factores de
producción juntos van a representar la
granja y como resultado se van a
producir alimentos cuando las personas
hablan de capital como un factor de
producción a veces se refieren a este
concepto de una manera muy estrecha
siente para cada uno de estos sectores
como la tierra y el agua engloban todos
estos factores como capital pero cuando
las personas hablan en términos más
generales especialmente si nos enfocamos
en este libro donde se habla de mano de
obra contra capital en este contexto el
capital agrupa y representa todo esto
cuando se habla solamente de estas dos
categorías así que todo esto es el
capital
y una forma de pensar en el capital es
pensar en aquellas cosas que son
nuestros bienes las cosas que tenemos y
que tienen un valor las cuales pueden
darnos beneficios futuros son todas esas
cosas que podemos comprar y vender
podemos pensar en otras empresas aquí
otras cosas que pueden producir algo
digamos que ustedes tienen una mina
dibujamos el círculo que representa la
operación de una mina
y si es una mina de oro va a producir
oro cuáles serán las entradas que vamos
a necesitar aquí
sin duda vamos a necesitar mano de obra
mineros y personas que administran la
operación de la mina pero además de esto
necesitaremos otras cosas como energía
para operar el equipo y de hecho eso
también lo tengo que poner en la granja
como la energía del sol y como la
energía eléctrica para operar el equipo
la cual puede ser que se compre o se
produzca y en la mina también
necesitaremos equipo y también
necesitaremos insumos podría incluir la
energía como un insumo si quisiera
ejemplos e insumos pueden ser
refacciones para el equipo o comida para
los trabajadores y finalmente vamos a
necesitar tierra para tener acceso a
nuestra mina en términos muy generales
pueden ver todo esto como capital por
supuesto también tenemos la mano de obra
está la juntamos con el capital y
producimos oro otra idea muy común tanto
en la vida diaria como en el libro
es la del rendimiento rendimiento del
capital
el rendimiento del capital
la cual es una medida de dado el valor
de capital empleado cuánto ingreso
obtenemos de ese capital por ejemplo
veamos la granja el valor total de todo
este capital digamos que es y aquí voy a
inventar una cantidad desde un millón de
dólares el valor total de la tierra
energía agua equipo insumos etcétera el
valor del capital es de un millón de
dólares
ahora vamos a suponer que el ingreso de
esta granja después de haber pagado la
mano de obra es más vamos a ver esto en
términos generales imaginemos que los
alimentos que producimos en la granja
tienen un valor en el mercado de 100 mil
dólares estos 100 mil tenemos que pagar
la mano de obra la cual es de 50 mil 50
mil dólares van a la mano de obra
digamos que esto es para cierto año
usamos el capital y la mano de obra para
producir 100 mil dólares en alimentos 50
mil van a la mano d
obra cuál será el rendimiento de nuestro
capital pues nos quedan 50.000 después
de pagar la mano de obra para el capital
o mejor dicho para los dueños del
capital para los dueños de la granja los
dueños de la granja recibirán estos
otros 50 mil dólares nuestro rendimiento
del capital será de 50 mil es lo que
recibe el dueño del capital de esta
inversión de un millón de dólares esto
será igual a 5 entre 100 y 5 por ciento
se tiene un rendimiento de capital del 5
por ciento si invertimos un millón de
dólares recibiremos 50 mil si tuviéramos
un rendimiento de capital del 6 por
ciento que invirtiéramos un millón de
dólares recibiríamos 60 mil dólares
ahora que ya tenemos comprendido este
concepto veamos una gráfica interesante
del libro de piquet y la pueden ver en
el sitio web piketty punto
en ese punto en ese punto efe rr
diagonal en diagonal capital 21 ce aquí
se encuentran todas las gráficas de su
libro las cuales se prestan para
análisis interesantes el autor ha
reunido toda esta información sobre el
capital y la esclavitud en los eeuu
lo interesante de esto es que al
estudiar la historia de este país se
habla mucho sobre la esclavitud y nos
damos cuenta que en ese entonces los
esclavos eran considerados como capital
aun cuando esto nos parezca aborrecible
ahora los esclavos no eran considerados
como una mano de obra sino como capital
algo que podían comprar o vender algo de
lo que eran dueños y lo cual les podría
generar futuros ingresos esto nos da una
idea de cómo ha cambiado o evolucionado
el capitalismo en la historia al menos
en eeuu en 1770 la tierra de cultivo
representaba un valor considerable del
capital como porcentaje del ingreso
nacional
bastante más grande del que tiene
actualmente otra tendencia es del otro
capital doméstico que se ha vuelto más
valioso recientemente pero cuál es este
otro capital doméstico son cosas como
infraestructura tecnología tecnología
mecánica es decir autos trenes camiones
y autobuses fábricas o incluso puede ser
software o computadoras pueden ver que
desde la revolución industrial el valor
de otras formas de tecnología u otras
formas de capital diferentes a la tierra
de cultivo se han vuelto cada vez más
importantes para nuestra economía
obviamente la esclavitud terminó a
mediados de la década de 1860 por lo que
desaparece de la gráfica pero es una
forma interesante de pensar acerca de
las tendencias macroeconómicas en los
eeuu
la tierra de cultivo en 1770 en un
factor muy grande de producción y aún
nos sigue siendo seguimos necesitando la
tierra para producir cosas la
agricultura obviamente no puede
desaparecer sin embargo en la economía
ha crecido considerando otras cosas
además de la agricultura en 1770 la
tierra de cultivo era una gran parte de
la economía pero ahora es una parte
mucho más pequeña de esta esta es una
manera interesante de visualizar todo el
capital tanto público como privado el
capital público es aquel cuyo dueño es
el gobierno mientras que el capital
privado es aquel cuyo dueño es un
individuo privado o empresas
en promedio vemos más o menos que el
valor total del capital ha sido cuatro o
cinco veces el valor del total de la
salida de producción del país